it was just supposed to say who lives on
Sol decal loves aren't soda at tea
painted now people are stopping me on
the street of course we would always try
to make each other laugh one of the
times we both just cracked up at a live
show and they kept it Nickelodeon
actually kept it I think I took a burger
and turn it into a shake and turn back
around Kimmy just broke it in I broke it
we just both started cracking up
laughing coach Crean was a lot of fun
just because there's a lot of physical
comedy and I knew I get to tear up the
place service it and scream a love
physical comedy and anytime I can get
really physical I love those moments
[Music]
Amanda okay her talent is amazing like
her physical comedy like she was never
scared to like get physical and they
were like you know she wants to do
physical comedy like how you do and I
just gave her a lot of pointers she took
it around with it she's a beast she's
fearless
so that's iLike tall of a man to see and
she was another one that was really fun
to watch Amanda so grazie
[Music]
the friendship cuz that's where it
initially started and hanging out if
they were like this needs to be a show
having fun and having a friends back
yeah that's definitely like me as far as
the other crazy stuff that he would do I
we mess up stuff that means so much I do
love playing that character man he just
say this awesome yeah it's between
welcome to good burger and who loves
orange so anywhere I go I'm treated like
the Burger King if I order anything at a
restaurant and it's not orange soda
you're supposed to be drinking sodas
don't be scared to like come up and ask
me if you see me in person and talk
about on a soda and burgers I'm not
gonna like spilled orange soda in your
face it's all good oh I drink a lot I
went Sona said and it wasn't like just
little bottles or cans of orange soda I
mean these were leaders that I was just
being juggled that's why we just do
anything they're like he'll just does
anything
well I'm having a lot of fructose inside
of me that's a good one um the
conversations have started something to
order everything's coming back it would
definitely be awesome and there was a
meeting but they're just working out
every being contractually so just keep
your ears to the streets
I would say just have fun and enjoy it I
was ready to battle I just had the heart
of lion like I was like this every
sketch I'm about to make it the funniest
thing you've ever seen I would say just
have a little bit more fun with it but
also still keep that intensity because
it definitely works how about orange
soda and just hang out and chill
what up kill some kill I'm good I'm good
you got you're gonna be just amazingly
handsome you're still gonna say the same
you're gonna be great man just you stay
right eat the right foods
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]